Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Enfrente tenía un texto
absolutamente incomprensible.
No entendía nada.
No sabía por dónde arrancar.
Primer parcial de Griego II,
segundo año de Filosofía.
El tiempo pasaba y yo veía
cómo muchos de mis compañeros
se levantaban a preguntarle al profesor,
el profesor hablaba y ellos volvían
contentos, se sentaban y escribían.
Siempre me pareció desleal preguntarle
al profesor durante un examen.
Nunca lo había hecho antes.
Ni siquiera conocía la dinámica.
O sea, ¿cómo era? ¿Ibas,
le preguntabas, te decía todo y listo?
Pero estaba desesperado,
así que me levanté y le dije:
"Profesor, no tengo ni idea
de cómo traducir esto.
Estoy absolutamente perdido".
Y para mi sorpresa,
me empezó a decir todo:
"Este es el verbo, este es el sujeto,
este es el predicado".
"Ajá", me dije,
así es como aprueban los demás.
(Risas)
Entonces, volví a mi banco, copié
la traducción según sus indicaciones
y entregué el examen.
A las pocas semanas trajo
los parciales corregidos.
Ni una marquita roja tenían.
Ni una corrección.
Cuando me lo entrega, me dice:
"Carman, tiene un 5".
"¿Pero cómo profesor, si está perfecto?"
"Sí, pero se lo hice yo".
(Risas)
Rodolfo Buzón, se llama.
Y en ese momento ni se me cruzó
por la cabeza que unos 20 años después
íbamos a estar traduciendo juntos
un libro
que nunca había sido traducido
al español del gran Aristarco de Samos.
Y no solo traducirlo sino también
hacer una edición crítica.
Cuando vos traducís,
tenés enfrente un texto
pero no sabés qué tan fiel es ese texto
al original que escribió Aristarco,
porque el original de Aristarco se perdió.
¿Qué tenemos nosotros?
Un montón de manuscritos que
se escribieron mil años después
y que para colmo no coinciden entre sí
porque están llenos de errores.
Hacer una edición crítica
es agarrar todos esos manuscritos,
ver cuál se copió de cuál,
armar una especie de árbol genealógico,
para finalmente proponer
el texto que para vos
es el más parecido
al que escribió Aristarco.
Y eso es lo que queríamos hacer.
Conseguimos todos los manuscritos,
unos 30, y nos pusimos a estudiarlos.
Miren, este es el manuscrito
más antiguo que tenemos de Aristarco.
Miren qué belleza.
Pero, como podrán observar,
no es fácil ubicarse en el texto.
No tiene subtítulos. Así que empecé
a usar los diagramas para ubicarme.
Y ahí me di cuenta de que
los diagramas del manuscrito
son muy distintos a los diagramas
que aparecen en las ediciones impresas.
Uno de los dos tenía que estar mal.
Miren, este es un diagrama
de una edición impresa
que representa un eclipse lunar.
El circulo más grande es el sol,
en el medio está la Tierra
y más chiquita la luna.
La Tierra le tapa la luz a la luna,
porque la luna queda dentro
del cono de sombra de la Tierra.
Este en cambio es el mismo diagrama
pero del manuscrito.
El manuscrito está mal; está todo mal.
El sol, la Tierra y la luna
tienen el mismo tamaño.
El cono se convirtió en un cilindro
y la Tierra, la del medio,
parece una pelota de rugby. Muy raro.
Chequeé todos los manuscritos
y todos los diagramas de Aristarco
y en todos pasa lo mismo.
¿Puede ser que Aristarco
no supiera dibujar?
Pero no solo Aristarco.
Lo mismo pasa con
los manuscritos de Euclides,
de Arquímedes, de Ptolomeo,
y de todos los griegos.
Todos tienen diagramas pésimos.
Había descubierto algo insospechado:
Los griegos no sabían dibujar.
Los griegos, los padres de la geometría,
no sabían hacer diagramas.
Ese fue mi primer descubrimiento.
Mi segundo descubrimiento,
que vino muy poquito tiempo después,
fue que eso ya había sido
descubierto antes.
(Risas)
Hacía ya unos 10 años
que había trabajos publicados
sobre cómo los griegos
hacían mal los diagramas.
Esos trabajos describían
los errores de los griegos
pero todavía nadie se preguntaba
por qué los griegos los hacían así.
Y esa era la pregunta más interesante.
¿Cómo un griego
podía hacer mal un diagrama?
Entonces pensé: "Los griegos
volaban en geometría".
Los problemas que ellos
resolvían con geometría
nosotros hoy los resolvemos con álgebra.
Por eso nuestras capacidades geométricas
están como atrofiadas y somos
mucho más dependientes de los diagramas.
Nosotros necesitamos ver
la luna dibujada más chiquita
para entender que es más chiquita.
Pero los griegos, no.
Y si no tenían esa limitación,
tenían mucha más libertad para
deformar los diagramas como quisieran.
Y entonces los podían alterar
para mostrar otras cosas.
Me puse a tratar de entender
qué me quería decir Aristarco
con cada diagrama.
Estudiaba el texto,
miraba el diagrama, y le preguntaba:
"Aristarco, ¿por qué?" (Risas)
"¿Por qué lo hiciste así?"
Y algunas respuestas fueron apareciendo.
En esta versión corregida del diagrama
se arma un lío tremendo con las líneas,
se superponen todas,
y no se entiende nada.
Quizás Aristarco
deformó el diagrama haciendo zoom
en esa parte para
que se entiendan las líneas.
Eso obviamente deforma el diagrama
haciendo que la luna sea más grande
y que el cono se convierta en un cilindro.
Pero a un griego no le preocupa
porque sabe leer el diagrama.
Otros podrían estar deformados
porque incluyen algo así
como una caricatura.
En una caricatura uno agranda,
exagera, lo que quiere destacar.
En este diagrama se quiere probar
que la línea roja
que pasa por el centro del círculo
es más grande que un diámetro.
Pero así no se nota.
En cambio,
si yo corro la línea del centro
como está en el diagrama del manuscrito
es más evidente que es más grande
que un diámetro.
El de arriba es una caricatura
del de abajo.
Eso obviamente hace que
la línea salga del centro.
Pero, de nuevo, a un griego no le
preocupa, porque sabe leer el diagrama.
Este es un mapa del subte proyectado
sobre uno de la ciudad de Buenos Aires.
Este, en cambio, es un mapa del subte
mucho más esquemático.
Lo importante lo tiene.
Pero para hacerlo esquemático
tuvieron que deformar
el mapa de la ciudad.
Así son los diagramas de los griegos.
Son más esquemas que
representaciones exactas.
O sea que Aristarco no los hizo mal.
No. Él los hizo así a propósito,
para enseñarnos algo.
Estaba feliz con esta idea. Imagínense.
Me llenaba de orgullo pensar
que había descifrado
un mensaje oculto durante siglos.
Un mensaje que Aristarco había dejado
para mí en sus diagramas.
Pero lamentablemente la historia
no termina acá.
Me pasé años defendiendo esta idea
en todos los congresos a los que asistía.
Hasta que llegué a uno en Barcelona.
Yo estaba ansioso porque
ahí iba a estar un profesor
que había sido jurado
de mi tesis doctoral.
El tipo es una luz. No había mucha gente.
Pero no me importaba.
Para mí yo estaba solo con él.
Me acuerdo que lo tenía
sentado a la derecha
y que mientras yo iba hablando,
lo iba relojeando
para ver sus expresiones.
Al principio venía todo bien.
Pero en un momento, cuando estoy
explicando un diagrama de Aristarco,
el tipo empieza a hacer [no]
con la cabeza.
(Risas)
En ese momento, mientras yo seguía
hablando y lo miraba, me derrumbé.
Me acuerdo patente que me dije:
"Este tipo tiene razón.
Lo que estoy diciendo es una boludez".
(Risas)
Nunca le pregunté por qué hizo ese gesto.
Pero no hizo falta, porque en realidad
su cara me obligó a enfrentarme
con algo que yo ya sabía
pero que no quería asumir.
Y es que había algo en
mi hipótesis que no cerraba.
Claro, yo siempre había supuesto
que los diagramas de los manuscritos
eran exactamente igual
a como los habría hecho Aristarco,
o por lo menos muy parecidos.
Pero el manuscrito de Aristarco
se perdió.
Por suerte, antes, algún discípulo suyo
habrá hecho copias
para repartirlas entre sus alumnos.
Y alguna de esas copias habrá terminado
en alguna biblioteca importante.
Tal vez en Alejandría.
De ahí algún estudioso lo habrá copiado
y lo habrá llevado consigo a Roma.
Y algún romano feo y bruto
habrá hecho copias baratas
para venderlas en el mercado.
Pero algún monje piadoso,
regordete y pelado
habrá comprado una
y la llevó al monasterio.
Y los monjes la habrán copiado ahí
durante varias generaciones.
Hasta que una de esas copias llegó
a las manos del rey de Francia,
que en 1266 se la regaló
al papa Clemente IV.
Desde entonces se conserva en Roma,
excepto por los pocos años
en los que Napoleón se la afanó.
Tal vez, todo ese proceso de copias
y copias y copias, era la clave.
Pero ¿cómo podía testear algo así?
¿Cómo podía recrear en
un laboratorio todo ese proceso?
En Historia no se hacen experimentos.
Pero apenas volví, yo agarré
a mis alumnos de la Universidad de Quilmes
y les dije que ese día
en vez de darles clase
íbamos a hacer un experimento.
Que ellos iban a hacer de copistas
antiguos y medievales.
Que ellos iban a ser monjes
regordetes y romanos feos.
Agarré a un alumno,
le di el diagrama bien hecho,
y le pedí que lo copie lo mejor posible.
Y que le pasara su copia al compañero.
El compañero sin ver
el original copiaba la copia
y le pasaba su propia copia al siguiente
compañero, y así unas 20 veces.
Les voy a mostrar uno de los diagramas
que les di a mis alumnos.
Es de Euclides,
y explica cómo rebota la imagen
de un objeto en distintos espejos.
El observador está en B.
El objeto está en A.
Pero la imagen del objeto
rebota en los espejos
y el observador lo termina
viendo del otro lado.
Euclides explica que el rebote de
la imagen forma un pentágono perfecto.
Miren ahora lo que pasa
con las copias de mis alumnos.
Esta es la primera copia. La segunda.
La tercera. La cuarta. La quinta.
El pentágono ya no es más
un pentágono. Es una casita.
(Risas)
Y la casita empieza a ganar altura.
Miren ahora el diagrama del manuscrito.
(Exclamación)
¡Es igual!
(Aplausos)
La copia, de la copia, de la copia
logró convertir el pentágono perfecto
en la casita del manuscrito.
¿Será entonces que los diagramas
son así por culpa de los copistas?
Lo chequeé mil veces
y siempre pasa lo mismo.
Les muestro otro ejemplo.
Acá Aristarco quiere probar
que el cono de arriba es más largo
que el cono de abajo.
Pero en el diagrama del manuscrito
aparecen los dos conos iguales.
Adivinen qué pasa con
las copias de los alumnos.
Primera. Segunda. Tercera. Cuarta.
En la quinta o en la sexta,
ya los dos conos son iguales.
Y se mantienen así, aunque
los sigan copiando hasta el final.
Y este es mi preferido.
(Risas)
Fíjense cómo rápidamente
en la cuarta o la quinta copia,
la Tierra, la del medio,
se convierte en una pelota de rugby.
(Risas)
El cono se convirtió en un cilindro
y la luna empieza a ganar tamaño
hasta ser del mismo tamaño
que el sol y que la Tierra.
Lo increíble no es que
se vayan deformando,
sino que siempre se deforman
hacia la misma figura.
Y una vez que alcanzan esa figura
se queda como congelado.
Y aunque lo sigas copiando
ya no cambia más.
Y es esa figura final la que
aparece en los manuscritos.
O sea que estaba totalmente equivocado.
No es que Aristarco los hizo así
porque quería hacer zoom
en una parte o porque
quería exagerar otra.
¡No! Él los hizo bien.
La culpa es de los copistas.
Fueron los copistas quienes copia
tras copia lo fueron deformando
hasta llegar a este estado de equilibrio.
Lo mismo que les pasó a mis alumnos.
La verdad es que este giro de la
investigación me desilusionó un poco.
Porque cuando yo creía que los diagramas
eran tal cual los había hecho Aristarco,
yo era feliz trabajando con los diagramas
porque cuando trabajaba con los diagramas
yo conectaba con Aristarco.
Y eso me lo robaron los copistas.
(Risas)
Pero sería injusto enojarse con ellos
porque si no fuera por ellos nosotros
no habríamos conocido a Aristarco.
Ahora veo cada diagrama como
una obra de arte cargada de historia
que se remonta a los griegos
pero que es también
una obra de arte milenaria y colectiva.
Como esas catedrales que tardaron
varias generaciones en construirse.
Donde cada copista fue haciendo su aporte
con pequeñas modificaciones imperceptibles
y probablemente inconscientes
pero que llevaron a esta belleza.
Yo no sé a dónde me van a llevar
mis investigaciones
en los próximos 10 años.
Pero de algo sí estoy
completamente seguro.
Y es que, pase lo que pase,
nunca, jamás, bajo ninguna circunstancia,
voy a volver a dudar de un griego.
Mucho menos de Aristarco de Samos.
(Aplausos)